Please welcome, Oliver Hudson.
(audience cheer)
(Oliver laughs)
Hello.
(audience clapping)
I've listened to you on stern.
I was, I pulled up into my driveway
and I stayed in my driveway for,
I don't know, 35 minutes.
Just to hear you.
So, I just wanted to tell you
how much I loved your interview.
Hi, I'm, I'm so relieved
(Oliver laughs)
to hear you say that 'cause, I tried to listen to it
and I was like, this is so long.
I can't, I don't know,
(Oliver laughs)
I don't want to listen to myself anymore.
So, that's a much nicer commentary than my inner voice.
And thank you for saying that.
And, I was listening, you know, to your podcast
about fatherhood. And, what was your intention
behind doing this successful podcast?
Well, first of all, Joe and I have been friends
for a long time.
Sort of unlikely friends.
No one would think that we are.
Joe, you know, his top priority in his life
is being a father.
He has girls who are 20, in their twenties.
And now, he has new twins.
My number one priority in my life is being a dad,
above career, above most anything, right?
It's our legacy.
It's what we leave here, really, you know.
And, I just thought it was an under-explored place.
And, we get real and we talk, you know, real stuff.
We don't hold back much and it's unafraid.
And we get to interview really great people
and hear about what it was like growing up
and how they father themselves or parents themselves.
And it's been fulfilling. It's been awesome.
It's just, it's been really, really fun for me.
You've had extraordinary guests, Alex Rodriguez,
Adam Sandler, Mark Cuban. The list is very long.
And...
Eddie Vedder.
Vedder was great.
I cried at the end.
I mean, he was like.
I, he's like, you know, I love you, man.
I'm like, I love you too, Eddie.
I was like, you know,
because I was talking about my own father
and that situation and it was, he was,
he's an amazing dude.
(Oliver laughs)
Well, one of the things that really struck me
when I was doing the research on this
was your relationship with your dad.
And I got very personally invested.
Your dad with Goldie Hawn.
My Mama. That's right.
The person everybody wants to be their mom
or their best friend or their sister.
I mean,
I know.
It's funny 'cause, when I was a kid,
I just railed against it.
I didn't want anyone to know who my parents were.
I wanted to survive by my own merit.
But, as I've gotten older, pride has kicked in
and I'm, yeah, I'm proud of, of who my mother is,
who my family is.
You know? I mean, dang.
You just want to have your own identity I think.
But, what I really got struck by was,
I felt a very personal connection with you.
Because you were talking about your dad
and how you were close with him.
And at a certain point, you guys,
became sort of a estrange. If you will.
Yeah.
And the thing that really knocked me off my socks
was that he and his dad, had had a similar journey.
Yeah, my dad and I have a,
we have a relationship now for the first time
in a long time.
And it was, it was spurned on by my,
dark sort of insane sense of humor.
You know, I wrote.
I Instagrammed and I said, happy abandonment day.
And, I was just trying to be funny.
It blew up, long story short,
it brought us together because it created a dialogue.
You know, but yes, so, I've done a lot of work on myself.
I went to this place called the Hoffman Institute
which was incredible for me,
more I learned forgiveness and compassion.
True forgiveness, true compassion.
And what that really means.
I went and looked into his life a little bit more
and understood where he came from.
So, it's, there's been a catharsis that I've had.
We have a really great relationship now.
And, it's just interesting how life plays out
and how things work.
First of all, the sense of humor with that post
and your dad, I think humor does save us.
And my mom was the same.
Her family was not there
and she was estranged.
And then, we repeated that pattern.
And, I think that, due to my own experiences
and my mom's experience, I was like,
I have to get this different.
I,
Yeah.
It's not right or wrong but I'm gonna have a determination
about this that may have not been there, otherwise.
And I'm so grateful for it.
And my mom and I are good now, too.
It's like, there's just some peace and respect,
and maturity there, that could not have taken place
maybe before. Timing is everything.
Yeah.
And, I'm just so entranced and enthralled by your journey.
And the fact that you're sharing it.
Everyone has, has a story to tell you know,
the, the, the parents, it's a tough thing. You know?
I mean, you, you, you are going through it,
and listen to you on stern.
No, you took the time that you needed to take.
You did what you needed to do.
You honored your children, you are faithful to your children
as you sort of put it.
And, it's different for everybody, you know.
And then, of course, Kurt raised me.
I mean, he came into my life.
He made me the man that I am today.
He's taught me some really amazing lessons.
You know, when I was growing up,
I was a momma's boy and my dad wasn't there.
And I had just my sister and my mother.
You know, Kurt came into my life and I kept hearing
independent than dependent.
These two words, I knew that being dependent
was not a good thing.
And being independent was sort of good and freeing.
And, I didn't understand the meanings
but I understood the sentiment of it or the feeling of it.
And I would hear that over and over.
We were in Colorado, we rode ATCs a bunch.
Kurt and I went down to the river, about a mile away,
and he just disappears at the river and I am freaking out.
Okay. I, we call him Pa.
And I was like, Pa, Pa... screaming my head off.
Finally, he comes around from behind a tree
and he was sitting there the whole time waiting.
Letting me feel what I was feeling.
And he said, Ali, Ali, all right. Relax. Calm down.
I'm right here.
I want you to get us home.
I'll be right behind you.
But you're the, you're gonna get us there.
And I was resistant.
Finally agreed to do it.
Looking behind me the whole way.
We get back to the place. I get us home.
And he says, look, if you were alone, you could get back.
You have to trust yourself.
You have to believe in yourself.
You have to know that you are capable.
You're, you are just a capable boy.
And something clicked.
The next day, I'm driving down the driveway.
I'm alone on my ATC.
My parents are having coffee.
And I say, Mom, Pa, look, I'm independent.
Not really understanding what that word meant
but just knowing that it was a good thing.
And from that moment on,
things shifted for me,
as far as my confidence
and my self-esteem, you know.
I love this so, so much.
(upbeat music)